we left off the last video at the end of
1789 the Bastille had been stormed in
July as Parisians wanted to get the
weapons from the best deal and free a
few political prisoners to in their
minds protect themselves from any
tyranny from louis xvi
louis xvi had reluctantly kind of you
know gone buying it behind the scenes
and said okay national assembly i'm not
going to get in your way anymore because
he's seen the writing on the walls at
every time he's done something it's only
led to even more extreme counter action
so we have this where at the end of 1789
already chaos has broken loose and a lot
of France the National Assembly they're
they're in process of creating a
constitution which won't happen until
fully happen until 1791 but they're
starting to bring things together in
order to draft that constitution but in
August of 1789 they've already done
their version of the Declaration of
Independence the Declaration of the
Rights of Man and the citizen so if this
was if everything was well we would just
wait until you know a few years we'd get
a constitution and maybe we'll have some
type of a constitutional monarchy but
unfortunate for especially for the for
louis xvi things weren't all well as we
mentioned all of this was propagated all
this was started to begin with because
people were hungry we have this fiscal
crisis we have a famine and so in
october october of 1789 were still in
1789 october of 1789 rumors got started
to spread that marie antoinette the
King's wife that she was hoarding grain
at Versailles so you know there's people
started ad imagining these big stacks of
grain at Versailles and this isn't a
time where people couldn't get their
bread and bread was the main staple of
the diet so there was actually a march
of peasant women on to Versailles and
they were armed this is a depiction of
the peasant women marching on Versailles
and they went to Versailles and actually
were able to get into the building
itself and they demanded because they
were suspicious of what louis xvi and
marie antoinette were up to adverse
they demanded that they move back or not
move back that they moved to Paris so
the women's March women's March it
resulted in and and they were able to
get their demands it resulted in louis
xvi and wife marie antoinette moving
back to paris moving back to paris where
they couldn't do things like hoard grain
and where they'll be surrounded by all
of the maybe not so friendly people who
could watch what they're doing and
there's also this was also precipitated
not you know I think the main factor was
that people are hungry rumors are
spreading that the king is hoarding
grain but there's also rumors that the
king was being very disrespectful to
some of the some of the symbols of the
new France of the of the new national
assembly so that also made people angry
and across the board everyone kind of
knew that and including louis xvi that
he wasn't really into what was going on
he wasn't into this kind of
constitutional monarchy that was forming
this power that was being lost to the
national assembly so we have this very
uncomfortable situation entering into
1790 where the the the king and queen
are essentially in house arrest in in a
building called the Tuileries in paris
you have this National Assembly drafting
this constitution they're they're
chartered to draft the Constitution up
there they all they all pledged to the
Tennis Court Oath and at the same time
throughout France you have some
counterinsurgency so this is France
right here throughout France you have
counterinsurgencies people who don't
like the the revolution that's going on
and then those would be subdued and
people are all plotting one against each
other and then you have some nobility
that says gee you know what I don't like
the way that this is going we've seen
already a lot of violence people are
angry I'm just going to take my money
and whatever I can pack and I'm just
going to get out of the country I'm
going to emigrate away from the country
so you start having nobility starting to
leave France they're called the emigres
I know I know I'm not pronouncing it
correctly but you see it you have this
notion of gee if I had it good in France
I'm not going to have
good much longer I better leave and this
same idea now that we get to 1791 so
1790 was just kind of a bunch of unease
now there were at 1791 the same idea of
trying to get away from the danger got
into the heads of Louis the sixteenth
and Marie Antoinette but they couldn't
leave the country they didn't trust they
didn't trust Great Britain they didn't
trust any of these other countries to
safely give them shelter so they one of
their generals who was sympathetic to
their cause said hey at least come here
to my to the frontier areas and you can
hide from all of the unrest that's going
on so dressed as dressed as actual
servants and they actually made their
you know shows you what type of people
they were they dressed as servants so
they dressed as dressed as servants and
they actually made their servants
dressed as a nobility to make them the
targets in case they were they were
ambushed anyway on their on their way
trying to escape from Paris dress
disturbance the king and queen the king
tried to escape to this generals estate
but when they were in Varennes
right here they were actually spotted
and then the people essentially took
them captive and brought them back to
Paris so this is called Niall you could
do this is you could imagine it as the
the flight to Varennes or the flight
away from Paris or however you want to
do it so already they the louis xvi
started to see the writing on the wall
they tried to get away but people
brought them back now you could imagine
a lot of people already did not like the
king they didn't like the notion of even
having a kin a king and the most
revolutionary the most radical elements
were called the jacobins the jacobins
and after the king and queen tried to
escape and came back they're like hey
gee what's the use of even having a king
you National Assembly why are you even
trying to write some type of
Constitution that gives any power
whatsoever to a king we should have a
republic we should have a republic
Republic which is essentially there's a
lot of kind of nuanced definitions
whatever public is but the most simple
one is it's a
date without a king without an emperor
without a queen so saying we don't need
you no you National Assembly you think
you're being radical but you're not
being radical enough we want to
eliminate the idea of having a monarchy
all together and the fact that these
that the monarch that that louis xvi
actually tried to run away we view that
as him abdicating the throne abdication
or essentially quitting abdication of
throne and they actually started to
organize in paris this right here this
right here is the shop's de mars i know
i'm saying it completely wrong so this
this is a current picture of it
chomp-chomp de mars and so they started
picking signatures in this kind of
public park in paris to essentially say
we don't need a king we want to
essentially create our own republic that
these National Assembly they're not
radical enough and so people started you
know they started gathering over here
and the Shump de mars and things got a
little ugly
so the actual the actual troops were
sent in to kind of calm everyone down
and these were actually troops
controlled by the National Assembly the
people you know the the people who are
mainly controlled by the Third Estate
but things got a little crazy throw
rocks were thrown at some of the troops
some of the troops at first they started
firing the air but eventually when
things got really crazy
they fired into the crowd and about 50
people died and this was the massacre
the massacre or the shop's Dick Schaap
de Mars massacre I know I'm saying it
comply my friends this isn't a video on
French pronunciation but you can imagine
how people are even angrier the King you
know people are still starving that
problem has not gone away the king and
queen has been kind of very reluctantly
everyone's suspicious of the fact that
they're probably going to try to come
back to power they tried to run away
when the jacobins or in general kind of
revolutionaries but they're led by the
jacobins when they start to suggest that
hey we should have a republic we
shouldn't even have a king and they
gather people here all of a sudden the
troops that are controlled by the
current National Assembly actually fire
on the crowd and actually kill
civilians for throwing rocks and they
might have been big rocks but you could
imagine this is going to anger already
hungry and already suppressed people
even more and to make people even more
paranoid that the king and queen might
eventually come back to power you had
two major powers all of a sudden trying
to insert themselves into the French
Revolution I'm going to do a little bit
of a side here because this is something
at least you know when I first learned
European history I found the most
confusing you have these these states
you can call them you have Austria which
I've which I've highlighted in orange
the the kind of map here is the modern
map but in orange I've kind of shown
what Austria was at that point in time
around 1789 1790 1791 in this red color
I have Prussia I want to show you that
these are very different than our
current notions of one Austria Austria
today is this modern country right here
and Prussia doesn't even exist as a
modern country and then you had this
notion of the Holy Roman Empire which
overlaps with these other kingdoms or
empires or whatever you want to call
them and I want to do a little bit of a
of a side here the Holy Roman Empire is
Voltaire famously said is neither holy
let me write that in is neither holy nor
Roman nor an empire and he was right it
was really kind of a very loose
confederation of German kingdoms and
States mainly German Kingdom states as
you could see it kind of coincides with
modern Germany and the two most
influential powers in the Holy Roman
Empire or that were kind of well
actually the most influential power in
the holy ramp Holy Roman Empire was the
Austrian and the ruler of the Austrians
had the title of Holy Roman Emperor and
that was Leopold the second so Leopold
Leopold the second was the Holy Roman
Emperor but it's not it's
not like he was like the roman emperors
of old with roman emperors of old
actually came out of rome notice nothing
nothing nothing in the Holy Roman Empire
at that time had no control of Rome so
it was not Roman we're not talking about
people who speak spoke Latin we're
talking about people who spoke Germanic
languages and it wasn't an empire that
it wasn't a tightly knit kind of
governance structure that it was this
loose confederation of states but what
the most influential was the was the was
the region that was under control of the
Habsburgs of Austria or leopold ii and
not only was he in control or without it
he had the title of holy role of empire
and essentially had control of the
austrian i guess you could say empire at
that point in time he was also marie
antoinette's brother he was also marie
antoinette's brother Leopold a second
that's that's her brother so leopold ii
and frederick william ii of prussia
which is another mainly germanic state
so let me do that in a better color so
frederick william ii they issued the
declaration of pillnitz let me write
this down so this is going to add even
more insult to injury to just the doubt
the general population of france the
declaration of pillnitz let me write it
here declaration declaration of pillnitz
and this was done in august so i just
want to make it very clear what happened
in june of 1791 they tried to escape
they were captured at Varenne then in
july of 1791 you have the sharp DeMars
massacre so already people are very wary
of the royals the idea that we don't
need them is is spreading and people are
getting angrier and then you have the
declaration of pillnitz by these foreign
powers one of whom is essentially the
brother of the current french royalty
and that declaration is essentially
saying that they intend to bring
the the French monarchy back to power
that they don't say that they're
definitely going to do it in military
terms or whatever but it's a declaration
that they do not approve of what's going
on in France and even though they
themselves might have not taken it too
seriously the people of France took it
really seriously you have these huge
powers on their on their border right
here
you had the Austrians you had the
Austrians and the Prussians so this
wasn't anything that you know people
people could take very lightly so it
only increased the fear that the Royals
were going to do something to come back
to full power and really suppress people
and it really gave even more fuel for
the Jacobins to kind of argue for some
type of republic so I'm going to leave
you there in this video as you can see
you know what we saw in the first video
things got bad now they're getting
really worse chaos is breaking out in
France people are questioning whether
they even need a king or queen foreign
powers are getting involved saying that
they hey we they don't like what they're
seeing there with kings and queens
getting overthrown maybe that'll give
ideas to their people and by the way I'm
your I'm your brother so I want to help
you out too that scares people even more
the current National Assembly which is
kind of the beginning of the revolution
they themselves are on some level
massacring people so it's really leading
to really tense and ugly time in French
history and you're going to see that
that's going to culminate with what's
called the reign of terror and we're
going to see that in the next video